[Music]
you
in this way then conscience acts and
preserves itself in the unity of its
essential and actual being in the unity
of pure thought and individuality it is
the self-assured spirit which has its
truth within itself in its knowledge and
there in his knowledge of duty it
maintains itself therein by the very
fact that what is positive in the action
the content as well as the form of duty
and the knowledge of it belongs to the
self to the certainty of itself but what
seeks to confront the self with an
essential being of its own is held to be
something not true
something stripped of its self
subsistence and only a moment
consequently what counts is not simply
knowing in general but conscience --is
knowledge of the circumstances it places
in duty as the universal in itself as
the content which it takes from its
natural individuality for the content is
one that is present within itself this
content in virtue of the universal
medium in which it exists becomes the
duty which it carries out an empty pure
duty just through this action becomes
established as something not
self-subsistent as only a moment this
content is the canceled emptiness of
pure Duty or its fulfillment
but even so conscience is free from any
content whatever it absolves itself from
any specific duty which is supposed to
have the validity of law in the strength
of its self assurance it possesses the
majesty of absolute autarky to bind into
loose this self determination is
therefore without more ado absolutely in
conformity with duty duty is the knowing
itself this simple self would however is
the in itself for the in itself is pure
self identity and this is in the this
consciousness
in paragraph 646 we're going to see
Hegel beginning a progression that's
going to run through the next several
paragraphs and actually really through
the rest of the morality section in
which what's going to be coming to light
what's going to be revealed through the
dialectic is the fact that conscience
can't really sustain itself in the way
that it would like to I mean the
paragraphs prior to this
we're in some respects almost like a
triumph for conscience right and what
we're seeing here is the the pinnacle of
that triumph but it's actually going to
turn out to be empty in certain respects
and where he's going to go from this has
to do with bringing in the others but
first we have to get to this this
emptiness and it's happening at the very
point where it seems like conscience has
managed to monopolize morality and this
is this is a familiar movement actually
we should stop for a minute and dwell on
this anytime that we manage to get
ourselves in the course of this
dialectic to what appears to be like a
total win a total triumph a total
resolution
there's always something lurking in the
background that we we missed and it's
really easy for the person of conscience
to do this according to Hegel and Hegel
notice he's not actually on the side of
conscience he's just charting out what's
happening so he says in this way that
conscience
acts and preserves itself in a certain
unity and we're going to come back to
that unity at a moment I've got a chart
here where I want to look at very
quickly is is the last part of this
paragraph where he says that in the
strength of its own self assurance it
possesses the majesty of absolute
autarky now that sounds again like a
triumph like a win like conscience has
dominated the scene an absolute autarky
now what is autarky turkey is
self-sufficiency and if we go back to
not just you know modern ethics but we
go back to ancient epics and which was
concerned with things like happiness
virtue one of the central preoccupations
that you see in platonic ethics in in
stoic ethics in Aristotelian ethics and
epicurean ethics is autarky this
capacity to suffice to oneself and to be
able to call the shots in certain ways
within the scope of one's life and here
we might say within the scope of what
Hegel much earlier was calling the
ethical substance one becomes the
ethical substance so one is the work he
says the the majesty of absolute autarky
to bind and loose this self
determination is therefore without more
ado absolutely in conformity with duty
which is what we've been charting out
this entire time duty is the knowing
itself this simple self hood is the in
itself and we'll come back to that in a
moment there's a few more lines after
that but I want to go through how we're
going to get there so let's come back to
the start of this this paragraph in this
way conscience acts and preserves itself
in the unity now here there's a little
bit of a I won't call it a
mistranslation but it's certainly a
interesting translation choice that's a
little bit misleading but on Miller's
part where he says the unity of its
essential and actual being in the unity
of pure thought and individuality you
know the unity of pure thought and
individuality not a problem but
essential and actual being what we'd
expect to see there is Vaes and lukas
and veer cletus right this is this
interplay that's been going on the
entire time but what Hegel is actually
saying is it's it's you know on Anzhi
sign wound for a zigzag so the unit
of its being in itself and it's being
for itself that's a little bit more
typical language and can you read that
as essential an actual yes I guess but
what's being emphasized here is being
for itself being aware of one's own self
which I suppose you can say is happening
through individuality is the being in
itself essential yes I suppose in a
certain way more important here is pure
thought being opposed to individuality
right so what's the pure thought going
to be here the pure thought of duty
which is going to turn out to be
ultimately empty but here it's being
said to not be empty because this unity
is going on and Hegel tells us it what
is it
conscience is the self assured spirit
which has its truth within itself in its
knowledge and therein as knowledge of
duty now you might say well that sounds
very abstract and very conceptual and
very cognitive remember that what we're
talking about here is not you know
knowledge and appear speculative sense
of knowledge of the universe or of
metaphysics in metaphysics in a certain
way metaphysics of morals to use Kant's
terminology or metaphysics of human
nature an anthropology that's going on a
moral anthropology sometimes what we
call also moral psychology which which
has metaphysical aspects to it as well
so what's what's the knowledge here it's
a practical knowledge it's a knowledge
not just of how we ought to act but what
Duty is in this case and so it's getting
to define a conscience is getting to
define it the individual who is also
sort of stepping into the shoes of pure
thought is getting to define it and it
says it maintains itself therein in this
unity by the very fact that what is
positive in the action and we'll come
back to that in a moment
belongs to the self to the certainty of
its
right so the certainty that it possesses
and remember we always have this
dialectic going on throughout the
phenomenology where we have certainty
and then we want to attain the truth of
that certainty and in the process
typically lose that certainty but gain
the truth and then we want to come back
again from the truth and get that
certainty back and bringing those two
together is very much like trying to
bring together two magnets that are you
know charged against each other because
they have the same charge actually and
it's tough to do isn't it in in Hegel's
schema but that's what's what's going on
here so we're going to have an
opposition going on in a moment between
again he says what's what's positive in
the action which belongs to the self and
then what seeks to confront the self
with an essential being of its own and
we'll get to that in a moment but first
what is positive in the action well
three things that have to do with duty
the content in halt of Duty
circumstances you know the particular
thing that's being said we ought to do
you know it might be to make money so
you can support your kids it might be to
sit down and do a lesson plan so that
your students can actually understand
what you're doing you know make some
PowerPoint slides because students
sometimes want those right even though
it's not a very good pedagogical
technique students want to have slides
sometimes or it could be you know doing
good to your neighbor loving everybody
it could be any one of those things that
could be the in halt of duty and then we
have the form of duty as well and form
and content are correlative right the
form is something more Universal and you
know if you think about we've talked
about this quite a bit
Hegel is not just targeting Conchie and
morality here there's all sorts of other
Enlightenment moralities that kind of
fit together into this and we can also
talk about you know some religious
morality the form is important it's it's
what allows us to say that there's a
generalization going
that it's not just me and my own
particularities deciding right and then
he brings in a third thing knowledge of
duty content form knowledge the
knowledge of the duty is something he
says positive and we're going to come
back to that in just a moment but let's
talk about what the conflict is here so
he says that what is positive in the
action belongs to this self to the
certainty of itself
what seeks to confront the self with an
essential being of its own is held to be
something not true something stripped of
its self substance and only a moment
only a moment only something that's part
of a larger whole a larger gestalt shape
of consciousness a larger back-and-forth
of dialectic now what what is this dad's
confronting it we might be tempted to go
to our unity here and say okay well
what's actually confronting the self
with an essential being of its own is
this pure thought but the pure thought
has now been you might say taken up by
by the individual conscience right so
where would this other essential be it
could be a niggle doesn't tell us at
this point right but we could presume
that perhaps it could be the claims of
another person or group perhaps it's
some other moral teaching about duty
that the individual is saying yeah okay
I recognize you have some some good
points there but I'm not going to buy it
because I get to decide I am to use the
phrase going a little bit back
I am the out arc right I'm the one who
is self sufficient so he goes on and he
says it
what seeks to confront the self now that
implies a certain agency right with an
essential being of its own is held to be
something natural something stripped of
its self substance and only a moment
so then Hegel goes on and he says
consequently what counts is not simply
knowing in general but conscience --is
knowledge of the circumstances and you
know here we could say with any kind of
morality when you're teaching it when
you're confronting somebody with it if
you want them to actually follow it
there has to be a buy-in on their part
by in meaning that they say okay I
recognize this I view it as valid I
decide that I'm going to incorporate it
I mean in a way we're kind of looking
ahead to Sartre and his comments of that
well if you listen to the priest it's
you choosing to listen to the priest
right we could say that Sartre
inhabits a era in which this sort of
thing has become a underlying norm for
for consciousness according to him a
little bit of a digression but also kind
of an interesting thing to think about
is it not so Hegel goes on and he says
what counts is not simply knowing in
general conscience knowing know of the
circumstances it places in duty as the
universal in itself nested
takes from somewhere from where it's
natural individuality and what is
natural individuality well we've
encountered this plenty in the morality
section plenty before that it is the
circumstances of one's own life
condition where one is right all the
things presumably not just having to do
with you know how old you are location
things like that but everything about
you your relations with others as an
individual within a fabric so your
familial relations for example I have to
take my guidance for what I need to do
in terms of providing for family from my
family members who may be different than
your family members I mean we can still
generalize about this but that's where
conscience is taking it's its basis so
he says it takes this content from its
natural individuality why the content is
one that's present within itself this
content in virtue of what the universal
medium
in which it exists now what's the
universal medium pure thought in this
case right again we're still at this
unity that's been held up and and
achieved at this point he says this
becomes the duty which it carries out an
empty pure duty just through this action
becomes established as something not
self subsistence so oftentimes we
encounter duty as this imperious command
falling on us now can't of course try to
say well the categorical imperative
which you're all bound by don't get to
make any exceptions and you better use
you know humanity as humanity as an ends
don't use it as a means and all it's
like it falls on your right it's it's
something that's seemingly coming from
the outside but constants know it's
coming up from within your own
rationality Hegel here is saying
conscience can say screw you I'm the one
who decides not you can't not something
that you're presumably finding in me I
get to decide and I'll make the
important decisions here thank you very
much so you know is this a certain kind
of stubbornness or obstinacy in earlier
stages it would have been but right now
this is what practical reason is led us
to this is a practical reason that goes
beyond the consciente road I'm does it
not well we'll see so he goes on and he
says it becomes the duty which it
carries out empty pure Duty is
established as something not
self-subsistent only a moment this
content is the canceled emptiness of
pure Duty or its fulfillment but even so
conscience is free from any content
whatever now we just said that wait wait
a second conscience has a content as an
individual
yeah but conscience can decide what
content is going to count as content it
can push some off into this emptiness of
pure duty and then pick something else
so if I have to decide between as we saw
before alternatives of should I like
love my neighbor should I
you know accumulate money so I can take
care of myself and my family should I
follow this moral command this moral
command that I'm actually ratifying
particular content here I'm the one who
decides it
I am the conscience I get to pick what
what is going to count for me and he
says conscience absolves itself from any
specific duty which is supposed to have
the validity of law doesn't mean that it
doesn't follow any specific duties it
just means that it gets to decide which
one is going to have the validity of law
we come back to that phrase that I
brought up in the strength of its own
self assurance it possesses the majesty
of absolute autarky to bind and loose
this self determination is therefore
without more ado absolutely in
conformity with duty duty is the knowing
itself the simple self hood however it
is the in itself for the in itself is
pure self identity and this is in this
consciousness now Hegel is not saying
here's here's where the slide begins in
the downfall starts but that's actually
what's happening here whatever we have
something that is at this stage of the
in itself right and we have something
like pure being or something that just
is the way it is expect there to be some
unpacking and some dialectical
advancement past that
this pier knowing is immediately a being
for another for as pure self identity it
is immediacy or being but this being is
at the same time the pure Universal the
self hood of all in other words the
action is acknowledged and therefore
actual this being is the element where
by conscience stands directly in a
relation of equality with every self
consciousness and the meaning of this
relation is not an impersonal law but
the self of conscience
paragraph 647 is one of those short but
very dense and important transitional
points as we just saw in the previous
paragraph 646 we have conscience as
being this this individual and also
unity with the universal able to decide
for itself which duties it's actually
going to take on you know he uses the
word autarky their self sufficiency and
what we're gonna see now is that that
very self sufficiency that very way of
understanding itself is going to yield
us something quite different and bring
us back into the world of others and he
uses this term being for others in the
very first sentence so let's start there
and we'll say well who are those others
in just a moment so he tells us this
pure knowing what pure knowing the pure
knowing of whatever it is that
conscience knows its duty it's the
positivity of it's you know duty in
terms of content and form and knowledge
all of that stuff that that at the very
end became a in itself a pure self
identity this pure knowing is that and
he says it's immediately a being for
another now he's going to use this word
immediacy twice here and part of it is
by way of explanation
he says for as pure self identity it is
immediacy or being so let's let's
actually start with that pure self
identity Ziggs ELPS gleich height
literally it could you could say pure
self identity you could say equivalency
to itself equality to itself exchange
ability for itself it's it's all the
same right in whatever differentiation
it has it's still just what it is
it's it's in itself that's going to be
immediacy which is a way of translating
when middle bar heights which we might
translate a little bit more literally as
a lack of mediation and what what is a
lack of mediation well there's there's
two senses here right so mediation would
be something in between two things a
third thing in there and mediation is
provided in Hegel in a number of ways it
can be within the same thing where it
suddenly becomes more complex and one
part or one moment of it is mediating
another moment sometimes displacing it
sometimes downplaying it sometimes
actually destroying it in some respects
destroying it sort of by analyzing it
and showing it's not what it what it
really is but another way of mediation
which is going to be applying here comes
from other people comes from another
another in this case gleich height
another self and this is where he's
going right if we look at the the last
part of it he talks about self conscious
consciousness and why is self
consciousness important why don't we why
do we care about the fact that instead
of just saying conscience or
consciousness he's saying self
consciousness well let's think back to
that section and try not to just you
know imagine the master-slave dialectic
but think about what came before the
master-slave dialectic and what we
learned about self consciousness there
first of all we learned that human
consciousness is self consciousness and
self consciousness isn't something that
exists all by itself
the way that consciousness at least
pretended to it exists in relation to
another self consciousness right and
actually higgles being rather abstract
there it doesn't just exist in relation
to one other self consciousness it
in relation to a whole bunch of
self-consciousness
this is what it means to have a culture
this is what it means to belong to a
group this is what it means to develop
as a human being in concrete ways from a
little tiny baby you know learning all
sorts of stuff as a kid and being you
know inheriting and sometimes
questioning and fighting against but
also taking in all sorts of things that
have to do with with morality right and
we should point out here we're gonna
come back to this self consciousness
thing in a minute this pure knowing this
is a practical knowledge right it is not
a purely theoretical or speculative
knowledge it is about handling it which
is behavior how we act our actions and
it's about duty and it's also about
something very important so here we come
back to thinking about self
consciousness again what is it that self
consciousness really really wants you
might say well to know itself yeah okay
that that's important you know to eat
that's also important to do the right
thing yes that's that's nice to to
understand the absolute great but what
else what is it really really after what
got us into the master-slave dialectic
what was the master looking for and set
him or herself up in such a way as to
not get it from the slave and then what
was consciousness self consciousness
looking for over and over again not just
through the rest of the self
consciousness section but through reason
and the rest of this spirit section the
German word for it is on-air Kenan and
what is the translation of that
recognition right acknowledgement the
two words that Miller uses over and over
again kind of you know swapping them out
every once in a while maybe so we don't
get so bored is acknowledgement and
recognition they're the same thing honor
Kenan here it's being used in terms of a
verb on air can't what is it talking
about our action our honda lung our
behavior is acknowledged and therefore
actual we'll come back to that in a
minute because
what's the relationship between being
acknowledged and being actual that's an
interesting question but what's
happening here is there is an
acknowledging going on between self
consciousnesses is this gonna be stable
is this going to be an achievement that
we hold on to how do we get there so we
start with this pure self identity or
self identity and immediacy and whenever
we have an immediacy inhale you know
that you know within a couple sentences
it's not gonna be median right and he
says but this being is at the same time
the pure Universal which is a being for
another in this case now the pure
universal what's the pure universal is
it the being of beings nope it is a
being of human beings it is what earlier
on we were calling the ethical substance
Hegel doesn't use that term here but
that's what we're talking about now
what's a human universal
well what's universal to us human beings
rationality is our rationality pure not
by a long shot and I don't just mean in
the in the respect that it's also
practical it's also you know something
that's individuated and requires us to
engage in all sorts of development and
all that but in this case it's the pure
universal and what is the pure universal
is it goodness itself or something like
that no it's something different
the self hood zel sight of all or of
everybody or of every single one Ollis
so the universal I'm the universal
deciding for myself as conscience I'm
gonna take on this duty and I say I
don't care what duty you take on I get
to decide for myself this is the one
that I really like I'm gonna be a parent
I'm gonna be a professor I'm gonna be
this right well everyone gets to do that
in the pure universal right and what
ends up happening at least for a brief
shining moment as we say is the action
of myself is acknowledged
and therefore actual what does that mean
Hegel goes on to say we're going to come
back to this actual in a moment that
what we have here are here he says this
being is the element whereby conscience
stands directly in a relation DeYoung of
equality with every self-consciousness
and the meaning of this relation is not
an impersonal law but the self of
conscience it is how I get to understand
who I am it's no longer immediate it's
being mediated by the other and this
recognition and I'm supposed to do that
for them as well right so he says a
relation of equality I wanted to dwell
on that for just a moment right because
a relation of equality is AG like height
like ID you know equality equivalence
exchange ability you could even say well
where did we see that zigzag like height
so we're moving from zigzag like height
to a like height that's in relation to
zeroing connection with others so this
is how my conscience becomes ratified
takes on reality you could say now let's
come back to this therefore actual right
via click isn't my action already of
your click I'm an individual I'm doing
things even if nobody else sees it even
if nobody else acknowledges it or
recognizes it and recognizes me it's
still real right yes and no it's real
but it doesn't have the full human
significance of something that has in
fact been acknowledged Hegel's onto
something here that that's quite
important about human actions it's not
just that they're intentional it's not
just that they can be motivated by duty
or against duty it's not just that we
choose them it's also that others in
some respect have a relation to those
other actions at least in principle they
can look at them and say oh you're doing
a good thing there or what
the hell are you doing I don't
understand that at all or mmm bad thing
to do there buddy that is is a part of
the significance of human action and so
what we're seeing here is it seems like
conscience has now expanded itself into
this harmonious community of all
something like what Kant calls the
kingdom of ends in his works now we're
going to see whether that it can
actually stay like that or whether this
is a transitional moment as I was saying
earlier
you